okay I have to take a poll to begin with
welcome to the Kirby Center how many
people have had a class with Thomas
Connor in this room and how many not
hold it sorry and so now that lets me
make it you know college presidents have
to be very diplomatic and never show
favorites and so I want to say that
there's two possible reasons why Thomas
Connor would have a slightly larger
crowd than Stephen Smith and and and I
want to be even-handed about this thing
I think it's either because history is
more important than English or else it's
because professor Connor is a better
teacher than professor Smith which is
invite know and what I know it with
interest is and I I when Smith was here
- we had standing room only most people
in the room had not had a class with
neither one of them and that means that
of the very many many people in this
town who've had a class with these guys
most of them have not come to their
lectures
you can probably tell Tom Connors a
friend of mine my name is Larry Arn and
I work at Hillsdale College and the
Kirby Center we just had a great two
days at the Kirby Center I've been here
for two days and the terrible and and
potentially fatal nose is there's
nothing but opportunity here right now
and the reason that it's potentially
fatal is why would a college that has
purposes that are eternal become
urgently important it would have to be
because the Eternals are forgotten and
Lord they are and if you walk around
this town and you talk to people about
those and it the college we're sick of
nature dust because how many people are
graduates of Hillsdale College here so a
lot right half the crowd maybe and most
of these guys are grown up now and
working but there's still kids to me
hello miss way how are you dear are you
mrs. something now about to be is that
guy gonna work out see how we treat them
and that's because they grow up with
this and we watch them right and it
didn't use teaching people who are 19
years old about the current thing
because the current thing is going to be
different by the time they get to doing
it so you need to teach them something
that lasts and if you do that that traps
you if you're an old person like me or
Tom Connor and the things that last and
you get good at those things because
that's your world and it so happens that
our country was founded according to the
things that last and it so happens that
those things are so much forgotten today
I was talking with a fella today he's a
member of Congress and he didn't know
that a law has been passed in the last
24 months and this law sets up an agency
that has regulatory authority over one
of the largest sectors of our economy
and this agency doesn't get its money
from the Congress it gets its money as a
percentage of the budget of the United
States Federal Reserve and the Federal
Reserve gets its budget from its
operations as a bank
it's the first thing like that created
in American history that I can find and
in the statute the Congress has
forbidden to hold hearings into the
operations of this thing and this man
didn't know that and he wasn't he's a
great congressman a wonderful he's a
friend of mine and he wasn't very
ashamed not to know that but of course
it's a fact that no one reads the bills
because they are unreadable both in
their volume and in the high and clear
quality of their composition and that is
a violation of a document that that
whole and I don't mean it's a particular
violent I don't mean there's a line in
the document of which it's a violation
it's a violation of the meaning of
constitutionalism as itself and that is
common now and I mentioned that to this
fellow and he wants help not to tell him
what to do but to tell him what is the
meaning of constitutionalism itself is
there such a conception is it a real
thing the current President of the
United States wrote in his first of his
two masterpieces of literature quote
sorry why was that funny
quote the very idea of ordered and
constitutional Liberty requires that
there be no absolute truth it's a quote
and by the way that isn't exactly
it isn't even quite a paraphrase of the
language of the Declaration of
Independence
I just spied my bishop back there you
see by the way everybody should go out
and tell that fella back there the black
one with the collar on that that I've
been a good boy today he doesn't really
know Nord nor do you the decorations
independent speaks of the laws of nature
and of nature's God for there to be such
laws there must be a reality a reality
that persists for there to be God or at
least for us to know him he must be a
reality that persists I'm introducing a
historian now Thomas Aquinas spoke a
term of theological and philosophical
meaning and also a political meaning
when he said the famous thing this alone
is denied even to God to make what has
been not to have been if there's
continuity in the present
there must be continuity with the past
and yet that is one of the many
continuities that is busted and that
gives rise by ineluctable steps to
unlimited law that is why it is my great
pleasure to introduce to you historian
of the old school he grew up in
Pennsylvania and therefore naturally is
a fan of the San Francisco Giants
I happen to have lived in Southern
California for a long time and learned
that those in the black and orange were
part of the evil empire but this man is
a bundle of contradictions and therein
lies the key to his character he
attended Elizabethtown College in
Pennsylvania and Hills his MA and PhD
from the University of North Carolina
Chapel Hill
he teaches some of the most popular
courses at Hillsdale College and that's
saying something he has a won the
Daughtrey award our highest teaching
award
he's one professor of the year voted by
the students twice he takes students on
tours of World War one in World War two
battlefields and I've been on them
myself and taken college friends
grown-ups on them too and they are
inspiring experience is those are
occasions the man himself is indeed
contrary contrary and it's a good term
because I will explain it he is a man of
dignity and good comportment he doesn't
like things that are out of sorts or
improper has a great sense of humor
nonetheless contrary and his students
called doc they all do
it's a seep down now so that the current
students except the freshmen who are too
afraid to refer to anything informally
they address the water coolers as mr
water cooler and they call him doc
because he lives in a state of
friendship with them when he travels he
takes students with him or he stays with
them where he's going or most commonly
of all he does both of those things they
look after him he's an old bachelor you
know they worry about him when I see
them they asked me how he's doing like
they're asking after a favorite uncle or
even a father he studies war and
contrarily he pursues the subject with
love you have not understood America or
war until you've been to a military
cemetery with Thomas Connor if you go to
the British with the American ones you
will see their quiet symmetrical
elevated upward looking white beauty
there are other countries young men who
gave the same sacrifice for those
countries and their cemeteries are
darker and if you go to the cemeteries
with Tom Connor you are not made to feel
superior over those cemeteries you are
made to feel the tragedy which is
present in both places and deeper
perhaps in the places where young men
give their lives for countries that are
not worthy of it and one does not
rejoice or vaunt over that rather he
mourns and Tom Connor teaches you to do
that Tom has founded a huge family in
the beginning his ability to teach which
proceeds from his character was the was
the foundation of the family but his
love his grand perception his deep
sympathy sustain it and make it grow
these account for the station he holds
he is writing a history of the American
battle monuments Commission he is the
best qualified person alive to write
that here at history by his
understanding and his character and he
is being cooperated with by the battle
monuments Commission itself and it
accounts for his holding his two higher
stages he is the greatest thing a man
can be he is a father and he is a
teacher
Tom Connor
I want to thank the president first of
all for that exceptionally warm
introduction and thank all of you for
coming tonight I must say as I was just
looking around the audience as the
president was speaking I said to myself
this is the first group of people class
room if you will with a bit of a stretch
where anybody's ever been drinking beer
in the room so I don't know whether
that's the future or not but I I'm very
grateful also to the Kirby Center staff
for issuing this invitation to me and
for all the help that they gave today
I've had the sense that I've been
stretching the muscles and the sinews of
this this enterprise all day long first
of all a little different room
arrangement so that you could see
pictures tonight and so that I could see
them too because most of the
presentations that I'm going to be
commenting on pictures to me it's
impossible to tell the story of the
American battle monuments Commission
without showing abundant pictures of the
remarkable sites that this agency of the
federal government has created since the
1920s so I've asked him to do that but
for those of you who know me also in
line with what President aren't said
about me PowerPoint is not my usual gig
but for the first time ever I'm going to
try it tonight and so I'll be moving
very gingerly up here because the
apparatus is set and I dare not hit the
wrong button prematurely but I want to
talk a little bit about by way of
overview this agency of the federal
government and in in this case I'm very
proud to say it's an agency of our
federal government it does
extraordinarily good work it's a small
agency
fifty to sixty million dollar annual
budget that's pocket change as the
federal government goes these days 400
employees most of whom are actually
foreign nationals because that's where
the bulk of the work is done and
particularly when it comes to
maintaining these beautiful sites that
you're about to see if any of you have
opened the pamphlet that was left on the
seeds for you don't necessarily have to
do it now although there might come a
time when the pictures get rolling that
you'll want to have the big fold-out map
in the center of the pamphlet as you
fold it all the way out because that
will map out most of the sites that
we're going to see but the foreign
nationals offer guide service and they
also do much of the maintenance work
which is lovingly and meticulously done
at all these sites the American the
American personnel basically serve as
administrative and offer leadership to
the agency the ABMC is an independent
agency one of the smallest independent
agencies in the in the federal
government and it has had a couple
narrower brushes in its history
with being absorbed into larger
departments but miraculously I would
almost say it has maintained its
independence and I think that's a good
thing
the mission of the American battle
monuments Commission of course is what
really defines it and it's it's a
hallowed mission many of you perhaps
know already what I'm what I'm going to
say but its principal responsibility is
to preserve and maintain overseas
military memorials and the predominant
form of overseas memorial of course is
the cemetery there are 24 military
cemeteries under the direct control of
the American battle monuments Commission
all of them overseas 22 of them are
World War one or World War two
cemeteries there's cemetery in Mexico
with remains of dead American sold
Mexican war and there's a large cemetery
in Panama which in which are buried some
of those who lost their lives during the
building of the Panama Canal during the
defence operations that canal when it
was still American and it is still that
cemetery in Panama is still a
functioning Veterans Cemetery which
means that it is still taking new
burials the other 23 cemeteries are
technically closed and the mission is
not only to preserve these sites but to
promote reverence for not only the dead
who are buried in them but for all the
soldiers who contributed to the
successful defenses of freedom and
liberty that the United States
participated in during both the world
wars and and even beyond that enterprise
the abmc to this day is actively engaged
in promoting what they call
interpretation in other words a deeper
understanding of the causes which were
at issue in the two world wars and which
claimed the lives of so many tens of
thousands of our soldiers so that's the
story that I want to tell a little bit
of tonight and it's the reason why I
think of all the federal agencies
perhaps that we can imagine this one
deserves our extraordinary respect and
and even gratitude and I would dare to
say that this may be the only time in
the history of these four walls that
anybody says anything that positive
about an agency of the federal
government but if this is the exception
I'm proud to be associated with it why
war and remembrance as a title I think
that that probably goes without saying
in light of what I've just shared with
you there would be no American battle
monuments Commission if it had not been
for the fact that the United States
fought in two great world wars and lost
men and then lost them lavishly as it
turned out not as lavishly as some
countries but lavishly all the
we lost 75 to 80 thousand dead in the
first world war four hundred thousand
roughly in the Second World War and in
Europe I think more than half of that
total in in World War two dead the rest
in the Pacific and of course as a result
of World War two the American battle
monuments Commission maintains memorial
sites not just in Europe but in the
Pacific as well the agency itself was
founded in 1923 which for those of you
who know your early 20th century history
you know that World War one ended in
1918 and just five years after that this
agency was created and the business
that's in obviously is remembrance
fostering remembrance and on behalf of
the entire country showing those who
lost their lives the survivors even
those who fought and are still living
veterans one of the most important
missions of ABMC is to show again that
none of that has been forgotten
among either the living war or the dead
I'm going to share with you a little bit
about how I got interested in this
subject I'll try not to be repetitive
the president knows all too well why it
is that I'm pursuing this work the
simplest explanation and by simple I
don't mean that it was the the most
motivating or remarkably nobody's
written this story before they're no
complete histories out there now that's
music to the ears of any would-be
aspiring author to have a chance to
write a book that nobody else has done
before they're particularly in recent
years there have been several books that
have come out with a lot of material on
the ABMC but still no complete history
so I hope when this book is done Lord
willing to or three years from now it'll
still be that way
but I have had the the the real reason
why I want to do it so strongly is
because I have had a spate of
wonderful experiences very touching
experiences at these cemeteries for more
than 30 years I remember vividly the
first time I went to Normandy for
example most Americans know that the
United States has a Military Cemetery in
Normandy most Americans do not know that
the American battle monuments Commission
built and maintains that cemetery but
Normandy is is only one again it's not
even the largest of the sites it's the
most frequently visited however and
presidents go there more than they go to
any of the other sites so that's the the
site that most Americans know about but
I've been going to these sites for more
than thirty years now and not just
seeing the places but conversing and and
meeting with the personnel and I've come
to conclusion that there's something
really special about these sites that
more Americans should know about and
there's also something very special
about the people who comprise this
agency so that's the main reason why I'm
engaged in this project but a third
reason it's because all my life as a
professional historian I have yearned to
find a topic related to the First World
War
to work on and yes I play a World War
two scholar on Wednesday nights and
spring semester at Hillsdale College but
my real passion I must say is for the
First World War and since the ABM sea is
a product initially of the First World
War it got another generation of work to
do sad work to be sure to create 14 new
cemeteries after the Second World War
but it's a product of the First World
War and its first chairman a man who
might have come to know I feel like I've
come to knowing very well in the course
of this study John J Pershing the
commander of the American Expeditionary
Force in World War one was the first
chairman of the American battle
monuments Commission he joined the
Commission he was appointed to the
Commission by President Harding in 1923
and he served as chairman until his
death in July of 1948 25 years
no chairman will probably ever come
close to that longevity of service
principally because sadly like most
other things in this town
politics have invaded even the selection
of the leadership of this commission but
in any case I had lunch today with the
chief of staff at a BMC headquarters
he's responsible by the way for the fact
that we have all these brochures tonight
which I hope you'll take home and really
take a good look at but the gentleman
with whom I ate lunch today said you
know Pershing was not just the chairman
of this organization he was the chief
executive officer of the chief operating
officer the artistic director the
marketing officer he basically ran the
show and just yesterday I was in the
National Archives looking through an
album of press clippings about the
dedications of the World War 1 monuments
we are living right now the 75th
anniversary of the dedications all eight
World War one cemeteries and 11
monuments were dedicated during the Year
1937 which happened to be the 20th
anniversary year of American entry into
the first world war and General Pershing
was interviewed by correspond of the New
York Herald Tribune the Paris office of
that in July of 1937 Pershing was on
hand for many of those dedications and
he told this reporter explicitly flat
out no equivocation he said when when
these monuments are dedicated this will
amount to the fulfillment of my life's
work as a Pershing said 20 years after
he had led the AEF to victory in the
First World War
and that's how close he was to all these
monuments he participated in the site
selection the design of the monuments
the procurement of contractors and and
architects
what have you he was involved in the
negotiations between the ABM sea and the
foreign host governments like the French
government the Belgian government where
most of the World War 1 monuments went
and he was lucky enough to live to see
them all dedicated former formally
inaugurated into service and it's very
interesting to me he almost died about
six months after the last of these
monuments was was dedicated and perhaps
I don't know how these who can know but
if he really did believe that building
that first generation of ABM seamen were
course he didn't know that there was a
gonna be a second generation that he
would also be alive for but he was he
spent the last few years of his life as
an invalid in Walter Reed Hospital
basically he was still chairman of the
ABM sea but not involved really in the
work but if he really had concluded that
his life's work was done maybe you know
that was subconsciously in part
responsible for the fact that he almost
had a fatal heart attack in February of
1938 but he survived that and wound up
supervising an effort during the Second
World War when the Germans had overrun
most of the memorial sites in France and
Belgium in fact the only sites they had
an overrun was Brookwood Cemetery in
England but Pershing supervised Daan
effort to see to it as best he could
from 4,000 miles away that the monuments
were cared for and preserved and that
the American personnel who were at
serious risk when the Germans went
sweeping through northern France and
Belgium were gotten out of those places
safely perching was very much involved
in that whole effort so his life's work
wasn't fully accomplished after all when
the construction of those memorials was
finished when Pearl Harbor was bombed
just to give you a little more insight
into the the character this man I've
been thinking so much about Pershing I
told Thomas so the intern story I
actually had a dream last night that
Pershing was present
Hillsdale College but in any case just a
day or two after Pearl Harbor was bombed
Pershing was the highest-ranking soldier
in the American army at that time he's
the only other man besides George
Washington to have been voted by
Congress the exalted rank of general of
the armies plural there have been
generals of the army but only Pershing
in Washington as I understand it were
generals of the armies so he dutifully
even though he was 81 years old wrote a
letter to President Roosevelt after
Pearl Harbor and basically offered
himself to the commander-in-chief for
whatever duty the the president might
wish to assign to him and Roosevelt
wrote back this this this beautiful
letter he said you're magnificent so
you've always been magnificent and
Roosevelt really didn't give him
anything specific to do but Pershing
just in shepherding again to the best of
his ability the abmc sights through the
danger of world war ii gave that one
last great act of service i would say to
his country after the war all the work
had to be done again 14 new cemeteries
designed and one of the things you'll
notice from the map the big fold-out map
in the pamphlet is where as with regard
to the World War 1 sites you see
cemeteries and monuments and they're
different they're different places often
very close together but there's still
different sites cemeteries and monuments
in World War two you'll see only two
ABMC monuments in the northern part of
France there and both of them in
Normandy Utah Beach Monument and plant
two Hawk mining where the Rangers went
up the cliffs but what the Commission
decided to do after World War Two was to
have cemeteries and memorials same sites
if any of you have been to Normandy for
example when you start down the driveway
to the cemetery you pass a sign normandy
american cemetery and memorial so there
they're sort of all-inclusive sites now
the world war two sites but all of them
were built and dedicated by 1960 the man
who replaced Pershing as a BMC chairman
in 1948 was George C Marshall only one
of the two or three greatest soldier
long with Pershing in twentieth-century
American history as Marshall presides
just like much as his old boss did over
the construction of the World War two
sites then Marshall died in 1959 jacob
Devers took over as a BMC chairman then
he was 6th Army Group commander I
believe in Europe his forces comprised
the right flank coming up from southern
France when they the front swung in
unified fashion to the east ahead into
Germany Devers and his crew were on the
right flank under general Eisenhower's
command Devers help to save the ABM C as
an independent commission in 1968 when
it looked like Lyndon Johnson was going
to merge the Commission with the
veterans Veteran Affairs Department
Devers wrote a letter to Eisenhower who
was still alive just one year before Ike
died I can self had served the ABM sea
during the late 1920s as a younger
officer helping to get a guidebook put
together to the World War 1 battlefields
Deborah's writes to Ike say hey it looks
like the ABM C is about to fall under
the ax what can you do about it I takes
up the challenge writes to Johnson and
within about two weeks time it was all
settled there would be no merging of the
agency Devers was replaced in 1969 Mark
Clark became the fourth ABN C chairman
the pattern you see I hope is not all
these got even pursing there's been a
lot written of very critical nature
about Pershing's generalship nobody's
really
assaulted his character I dare to say
but all four of these guys pursing
Marshall Devers Clark some of the most
prominent soldiers all army men of
course but for the first forty years
students 60 years these four men
provided leadership to this little
Commission since nineteen eighty five
there have been four or five different
chairmen again the terms tend to be
shorter
now the first slide I'm going to throw
up here is it's a composite picture of
all the chairmen and some of the faces
you might even recognize but I'll just
wrap up the the narrative overview and
then then we'll turn to the pictures the
work of the Commission will never really
be done hopefully they'll never have to
build any more cemetary sites the Korean
War dead and of course Vietnam War dead
were all repatriated we have overseas
cemeteries today because families were
given the choice the government decided
to build them obviously but families
were given the choice at the end of each
war as to whether they wanted their dead
son or dead husband or dead father
whoever might be brought back or left in
an American Cemetery and interestingly
at the end of each war the percentage
was exactly the same
61% decided that the war dead would be
repatriated 39% decided that they would
indeed rest overseas now Korea and
Vietnam all those guys were brought home
and so too has it been as best we've
been able all the dead of the wars after
that have been repatriated the most
recent things that ABMC has done that
you might know about it they built the
Korean War Memorial and they built the
World War Two memorial on the mall but
the minute those structures were done
and dedicated control over them passed
to the Park Service but the
understanding seemed to be that ABMC had
it in its genes somehow that they knew
how to build memorial
so they were given those tasks the
Vietnam Memorial was a different thing
but the real business of the Commission
now is preservation of the sites and
fostering remembrance and for those of
you who have been to Normandy recently
I'll show you a picture of this but
there's been a wonderful new
interpretive center visitor center built
it's only been opened up for five years
in Normandy but what goes on in that
building is exactly what I'm talking
about
there it's basically a museum but it's
it's not an ordinary museum the the
specific purpose of it is to tell the
stories of the men who fought and many
of whom died courage competence and
sacrifice are the three themes that
these interpretive centers are going to
emphasize and and it's a way again of
doing reverence to the memory of those
soldiers but also to the cause for which
they fought so let me see if this grand
experiment is indeed going to work there
we go these are pictures of the eight
men who have chaired the American battle
monuments Commission starting with
Pershing on the left
general marshal general Devers general
Clark
Andrew Goodpaster is the fifth
photograph moving from left to right
general PX Kelly the first marine
general Marine Corps general to chair
the ABMC general Kelly's the Grover
Cleveland of a BMC chairman he had two
terms that were interrupted by another
general Kelly who's still very much
alive and doing quite well just ask
after he today I'm hoping to interview
him at some point but he was appointed
by George HW Bush and then again by
George W Bush general uh Fred Werner is
the next the last photograph he was
President Clinton's appointee as
chairman and Frederick Franks who served
from 2005 to 2009 as the last picture
the current chairman is not
shirred up there's Air Force general uh
Merrill mcdr in the early 1990s the
statue of Pershing any of you I have a
shiny quarter in my pocket for anybody
who can name general Pershing's hometown
I'm gonna go out there and speak Lord
willing in September this little town in
northwestern Missouri about two hours
drive from Kansas City celebrates
Pershing days every September right
around the his birthday's September 13th
they had a really blowout
Pershing days festival two years ago on
the hundred fiftieth anniversary of his
birth no takers
now it's lacked lead missouri right
there but you know there's more
significance in this than then you might
imagine within about three hours if you
were to pick a central point and go
three-hour you've got Pershing's
hometown you've got Harry Truman's
hometown and you've got Dwight
Eisenhower's hometown so there's
something in the water
out in in that particular part of the
Midwest that produces great leaders but
humble men and in in some ways very
simple characters about them too now we
come to the first monument that we're
gonna look at this is on the battlefield
of the meuse-argonne the meuse-argonne
was the greatest battle that Pershing
fought and again this this speaks
further to the hands-on direction that
he brought to even the design of these
monuments he wanted the monument
commemorating his greatest battle to be
the biggest and he wanted them out of
the monument commemorating his second
greatest battle to be the second biggest
and third greatest third biggest so so
forth and so on this is a Doric would
that be the
the style of a column basic it's 100 100
80 feet high crowned by a Statue of
Liberty and it's actually built among
the ruins of what used to be a French
village there were a lot of French
villages of course destroyed along the
old western front you can see into the
ruins of the old village church from the
top of the monument but the first
mock-up of the statue for that monument
that Pershing saw had the Lady Liberty
sort of looking down and her head kind
of pitched as if she was sad
Pershing saw it and said no no she's
gonna be looking straight ahead no
sadness the motto that Pershing gave to
the American battle monuments Commission
time will not dim the glory of their
deeds time will not dim the glory of
their their deeds Pershing could get
plenty Reverend and solemn when he
contemplated he spoke at the dedication
of this monument for example in the 1st
of August 1937 75 years from what next
Wednesday
he knew the toll of the war but he
wanted the the soldiers to be remembered
for the good things made that the good
service that they had done to the cause
of Liberty so no Lady Liberty is going
to be looking down and looking sad he
actually went in person to the studio of
the artist who finally got to design
right in New York City to make sure that
it was as he wished for it to be this is
the sort of cornerstone the monument at
American battle monuments Commission can
you read the name of the architect John
Russell Pope yeah he's done a little
work in this town he designed the
Jefferson Memorial among other things
the this is the view from the top of the
monument
and folks you were as you look at that
picture you are looking at the bloodiest
battlefield in American history the
meuse-argonne cost more casualties than
any other single battle in American
history
now it was a 47 day long battle remember
under World War one conditions but it
remains the bloodiest battle and long
may it ever being may there never be a
bloodier one than that but this is the
view again that you get and you can
imagine if you kind of reverse it you
can imagine how that monument must look
from off in the distance and that was
all a part of the design as well this is
the the second biggest monument to
Pershing second biggest battle or the
AEF second biggest battle the sent me
how salient the south of Verdun and the
bat of the monument rests on the Butte
to demote sec mo NT sec you can follow
on the map if you wish but I've seen it
in the the documents the intention when
these sites were picked and the
monuments were designed was that they
could be seen for miles as if the
achievements of this American force
somehow project out into the infinite
spaces of of location as well as or
geography as well as time beautiful
design I think it's obviously
reminiscent of the Jefferson Memorial
perhaps and this is the view from the
top of Mont sec I was there in the
autumn of the year so you see a little
bit of color there this is the third
biggest monument this is just outside
chateau-thierry in France and it's in
the end
Marn area of the old western front this
is the first place really that American
forces saw action in great numbers and
very close to this monument is Bella
wood which is of course of immortal
renown to the United States Marine Corps
the chief architect for the a BMC man by
the name of Paul Craig C ret Paul
Philippe Cret he operated out of
Philadelphia Pershing pretty much
hand-picked him he was born French
served in the French army won the claw
Daguerre in fact in the French army and
then spent the last year - in the
American army and was an American
citizen in the 1920s when he was
appointed to this task but he designed
this memorial and it can be seen for
from miles away overlooking the Marne
River just south of Reims were actually
sorry west of Reims one of the things
you get on these monuments are maps
battle maps and this again just
emphasizes that the ABMC has always been
in the business of Education Pershing
one of the memorials to commemorate
lives lost lives given in service but he
also wanted the ABMC to commemorate
deeds and it was important for people he
believed to feel proper reverence in
order to feel proper reverence for the
deeds done to understand what in fact
was done how the fighting actually
played out this little town I visited
for the first time this summer [ __ ]
me and you know what happened there sir
exactly so right at late May 1918 yeah
they drove the Germans out of this town
and that was just a day or two or three
before the action in the a Marne salient
but got a lot of attention the American
troops of performed very well and this
is the Monument obviously smaller scale
but Pershing was on hand personally for
the dedication of this Monument in mid
August 1937 sits in the square of this
little very quiet little farm village in
France and the ubiquitous map and
commentary I think one of the reasons
why America
can seem not to know that much about the
First World War is well they're known
living veterans anymore obviously but
the sights are so remote not that World
War two took place on our soil it did
touch away and a lot of Americans get to
the Pearl Harbor memorial I'm sure but
for being so far away and and in remote
locations these places they're hard to
visit and people don't know about that
this is the monument it's on the P and
so Mme P Y on the map plaque there which
is very much in keeping with other ABMC
memorials view from the top you can get
to an observation deck this is in the
champagne iya area of France beautiful
country again this was the autumn of
2010 when I was on sabbatical courtesy
of the college but commemorative plaques
they're actually for I've only got a
couple here but but all the major
divisions that saw action in this
territory got a mention the dates of the
action and the places again the American
battle monuments grew out of a smaller
board that was wholly situated within
the War Department called the battle
monuments board that was created in 1921
Pershing didn't serve on that but he put
one of his most trusted confidant so
general by name of John McCauley Palmer
in the chairmanship of that board and
what the battle monuments board was
designed to do was basically mark
battlefields if you can imagine northern
France just almost covered by metallic
markers where American troops saw action
in World War one that was the intention
ABMC greatly refined and expanded upon
that mission but interestingly general
Palmer and General Pershing are within
speaking distance of each other same
hillside over in Arlington Cemetery on
to this day 36th division 42nd division
that was the famous
all together now rainbow division
because the men
it literally spanned the expanse of the
American nation so now this is the basic
look of the cemeteries
marble headstones in the shape of
crosses or Stars of David you see a Star
of David over the right edge of that
picture and very different look from
what you get at Arlington isn't it
because you know in Arlington most of
the headstones are much closer to the
ground and they're not of the design of
religious symbols there was a the
equivalent of a Donnybrook
during the 1920s within the commission
between the american battle monuments
Commission the War Department and
Congress got involved also finally it
was decided that the overseas cemeteries
would look like that and that the
religious symbols would prevail as it
turned out and of course then the next
Donnybrook was over the material it was
gonna be in the white marble of Italian
nationality as it turned out the
American granite Association did not
like that at all
but so even though again these are
hallowed sites they're not immune to
politics even from the beginning but the
look of those white crosses perfectly
aligned perfectly manicured on green is
just stunning and it's it's really the
the the trademark I think of these
overseas sites this is the chapel at the
meuse-argonne cemetery classical design
the world war ii chapels are are quite
different as you'll see for yourselves
in a moment but there's a longer view on
the Chapel of meuse-argonne and the
graves of course would be either side of
that row of trees that little fish pond
though in the foreground it was an
interesting story behind that in May of
1940 when the Germans came through
literally came right through this
cemetery there were planes flying over
doing bombing runs and and what
have you the superintendent's wife used
to go down and feed the goldfish part of
her daily routine and one day she was
literally chased back into the house
because there was shrapnel and bomb
fragments flying around some damage done
to the cemeteries it turned out it was
incidental but that's the kind of danger
to which I made reference earlier that
American personnel cemetery personnel
generally were exposed during the war
this palm was placed on the altar of the
chapel by the President of France in
1937 when he attended the dedication at
multiple call it's now high hanging on
the wall outside the superintendent's
office but I learned that for years
people forgot what this was and gene
Dillinger Larry a friend of ours who was
superintendent there for some time
started writing letters was he he wasn't
content not to know the significance of
that thing and finally somebody from
within the French government told Leo
that's what the French president left to
honor the cemetery on the occasion of
his dedication so now we know this is
what our cemeteries look like on
Memorial Day this is obviously a French
cemetery this is the Oise Ain Cemetery
our second largest World War 1 Cemetery
but French flag an American flag
side-by-side there's six thousand twelve
graves in that cemetery so that's over
twelve thousand crosses excuse me flags
that somebody has to put in there in the
ground by hand the Memorial Day
ceremonies are highlights of the year
for any given cemetery and they they
remind us that even though there are
thousands of dead obviously lying in the
cemetery they're living sites they are
outposts of remembrance for the the
ongoing perpetuation of the memory of
what the soldiers did and on every one
of the memorial days that I've ever
attend
in France there are great Eve occasions
and confirmations of franco-american
friendship as well this is the belleau
wood chapel this particular Chapel took
an artillery shell courtesy of the
Germans in 1940 the hole that the shell
left is still I don't have a picture of
it sadly but it's in there it didn't do
much destruction but again that reminds
us that these places were in a war zone
this is an inscription on the back of
one of the crosses for those of you who
know British war cemeteries you know
that the British give to each family
whether it's World War one or World War
two cemetery an opportunity to
contribute a verse
to the grave of their their family
member and to visit a British cemetery
and read those inscriptions is very very
touching well we tried that in the First
World War
and it just didn't work this is probably
the most moving of all the inscriptions
that anybody offered for the the back of
the headstone of their lost loved one it
for some reason maybe Americans aren't
as pro at poetic as the British I don't
know but the option was not even offered
to the world war two dead now the
families of the world war ii did now
this shot is a close-up
this is Carrara marble the World War One
cemeteries are bedecked in Carrara
marble and you see that I think it's a
lovely vein it's different on on each
one but that silvery vein runs through
it it's Italian marble it also is the
case that the bid from that Italian
quarry was lower than anybody else
including the American granite
Association so or any granite supplier
so that helped Paul Cody Bentley was the
son of the first woman to serve on the
American battle monuments Commission the
original Commission numbered seven
people the Commission today numbers
eleven the Commission itself is just an
oversight board kind of like
Board of Trustees if you will for the
for the larger agency but this woman was
on the Commission precisely because she
was a gold star mother you were a gold
star mother if he lost a son and that
was he this statue is somebody must have
asked for a photograph of that grave
marker because when the ABMC is asked
when when the cemetery personnel are
asked to do that
they rub Omaha Beach sand into the
lettering to accentuate it so that it'll
show up better on a photograph so that's
what that that was this statue is in the
Sandy Hill Cemetery below Verdun it is
to my knowledge the only private piece
of artwork in any of the cemeteries it
was given by the daughter excuse me
well her father was very famous James G
Blaine does that name mean anything to
you ran for president I think in 1892
President United States well his
daughter gave that statue in honor of
her son who was buried in the cemetery
the abmc initially refused permission
for that statue to be erected
but when General Pershing found out who
this woman was James G blamed daughter
he relented and it's a it's a beautiful
statue there's an inscription on it that
says in the English it's the the
descriptions French but he rests far
from his own in the sweet soil of France
this is the superintendent it's auntie
hell doing something that's done in
every one of the cemeteries everyday at
closing time the flag lowering and it's
a very moving day it symbolizes to
anybody in the military the end of a
duty day
and one of the superintendent's said to
me once that all those guys buried out
there or somehow still serving their
country they're still on duty as it were
now we're in the world war two
cemeteries and approaching the final
stretch here this is the Cambridge
Cemetery in England you can see how
different the chapel design is from the
World War One chapel more rectangular I
think less interesting architectural -
what do I know about architecture I just
know what I like
I guess you say but this general shot of
Cambridge did a lot of fliers buried in
the cemetery in Cambridge because for
the obvious reason that air operations
were principally what was done out of
England until 1944 anyway while the
missing here every Cemetery hasn't all
the missing names are listed on there
for whom no remains were found but the
Glenn Miller's name is on that
particular wall the band leader and this
is again part of the cemeteries ongoing
educational effort at Cambridge this map
is meant to depict the various paths
that Bombers took from the bases in
southern and southeastern England this
particular plaque in the chapel at
Cambridge of course is to remind people
that these cemeteries are supposed to be
somehow non-sectarian and but it
basically means Jewish and Christian
nonetheless very typical Chapel design
here the poppy wreaths now we're at the
Brittany Cemetery which is south of
Normandy the architecture of course of
that stone church is very reminiscent of
the architecture in the area
any time you drive through Brittany
you're gonna see a lot of houses build
out of that kind of stone
beautiful floral flowering bushes there
in the chapel inscriptions they're not
ashamed to resort to religious
inscriptions in the chapel many of them
are very moving
now finally Normandy be our last stop
this is for Memorial Day 2011 and you
see the French flag and Old Glory flying
side by side and as well as side by side
by each grave Memorial Day of course
used to be remembered as decoration day
so it's part of the tradition to
decorate the graves it there's a look
out onto the the see the cemetery
occupies Bluffs right above Omaha Beach
the American army would have fought
their way up those Bluffs and going
right across that ground on the day of
June 6 1944 this is looking up toward
the monument area
the statue of Normandy cemetery is of
youth rising from the waves I should
have had a picture but didn't I learned
a long time ago that Normandy was
obviously a very special place I've seen
more grown men cry in Normandy than
anywhere else I've ever been I'm utterly
convinced of that
two sons of President Theodore Roosevelt
buried side by side Theodore Roosevelt
jr. died shortly after the Normandy
landings in July of 1944 he got the
Medal of Honor that's why his the
inscriptions on his gravestone stand out
because they're gold engraved his
brother Quentin was actually killed on
Bastille Day July 14th 1918 he was a
pilot the first world war he was buried
miles from Normandy over in the eastern
part of France where his plane came down
in the last summer of the great war but
at the request of the family when the
Normandy cemetery was opened and
Theodore jr. was put in there the two
brothers will now reside side-by-side
and there are numerous sets of brothers
in that cemetery and
it's common in a number of the others
too this is the new visitor center I
have this picture mainly up there for
dr. arns benefit I don't think you've
ever seen this place have you Larry it
we found out it was going to be built in
2003 and and our first thought was we
found out what's going on the bluffs
that it was going to somehow spoil the
the view up there but they've tried to
be very discreet about how they they
built it low to the ground and it's all
but obscured by the vegetation there but
about a 30 million dollar project and I
would argue worth every penny oh yeah
it's been open for five years it was
dedicated in oh seven this is the last
picture this woman I think speaks
volumes about this whole phenomenon of
war and remembrance her first name's
Billy I don't know her last name but I
sucked this shot Memorial Day last year
2011 that's a cemetery staffer giving
her that red rose this woman fought for
years that the man she had married
during World War two
was missing that there were no remains
to
be found for decades literally she did
not know that her husband was in fact
buried in the Normandy cemetery when she
found out she remained as she never
remarried she she said that her love for
this man was indivisible and that was
the way it was gonna be so when she
found out that he in fact is buried in
some she comes back every Memorial Day
and all the staff know her and the staff
have told her story the story of her
husband and you know people know where
his grave is so many times that people
independently has taken upon themselves
to put flowers on his grave so his his
grave has decorated almost 365 days out
of the year and whenever she comes back
all those memories of course come back
with her and it's it's a good note to
end on I think because every underneath
every one of those beautiful headstones
is somebody's story we know a little
more about hers than many of the others
but somebody's story is is behind every
one of those grapes thank you
thank you and Thomas some of that
applause is for you Thomas of the the
mic man back there is responsible for
the fact that it was possible to show
those pictures so I fear that I've
imposed on my time limit quite heavily
but if if there we do have time for a
couple some questions tonight dr. Connor
in your opinion do you think there's
much of a chance that's an organization
of the nature of ACL you will be able to
do anything to remove the current
memorials in these overseas cemeteries
I certainly hope not I've actually asked
that question of cemetery personnel and
nobody seems to worried about it I don't
know whether it's the fact or that the
the issue is that the ACLU wouldn't dare
you know interfere with the beauty of
these places or maybe it's because
they're overseas they don't even know
about these places so if you if you have
reason to believe that the person you
may be showing that pamphlet to is
attached to the ACLU somehow don't do it
but but you know I mean I pessimism runs
deeply the older I get to I think and I
can certainly four see something like
that happening in the abstract but for
the time being
there doesn't seem certainly doesn't
seem to be much fear of it in in the
organization so your call Thomas
I just had a quick question I realized
that the nature of World War one in
World War two were different than the
nature of Korea and Vietnam but I guess
specifically why are there no memorials
on the ground in Korea or Vietnam yeah I
think the simplest way for me to to
answer that and there's a lot I don't
know about you know what calculations
might have might be behind that but it's
friendly soil versus unfriendly soil
there we didn't want to even attempt to
put memorials or have cemeteries on what
we thought might become or what was at
the time the war was over unfriendly
soil now South Korea is obviously
friendly soil but Vietnam is remarkably
friendly today I think but still when
when it was all over with it was deemed
unfriendly soil you'll notice on the map
there there no cemeteries in Germany
either and factors there's quite I think
there five cemeteries two in Belgium one
in Holland one in Luxembourg and one in
France all World War two cemeteries that
have about thirty five thousand guys
made about a third of the World War two
dead that are in ABMC cemeteries are in
these five cemeteries they're within 10
to 15 miles of the German border and a
lot of the guys in those cemeteries
actually died in Germany but their
bodies were not left in Germany they
were brought back to Allied soil so
that's that's the the best answer I know
to give you to that question
No there is a there is a British
counterpart to the American battle
monuments Commission it's called the
Commonwealth War Graves Commission and I
know one of the principles that the
British observed when it comes to
burying their their war dead burying
them permanently that's very different
from ours we tend to consolidate we tend
to have fewer larger cemeteries fewer in
number but larger in size in other words
not fewer larger cemeteries but less
number of cemeteries with more buried in
them
the British tend to have a greater
number of smaller cemeteries so that
they could observe the principle of
burying a soldier closest to where he
fell so now the the we're talking single
graves probably are we or collections of
them in Germany are they world war they
world war two dead or okay not not
Berlin Airlift or anything like that
okay
yeah yeah I guess again the only way I
would know to try to answer your
questions to say that the British are
observing that principle very closest to
where they fell and I noticed and
appreciated your distaste for the more
modernist memorials do you think that's
widely shared in your observation I
anecdotally I happen to know that man
who just retired as head of the ABM sees
European office general Hawkins the abmc
has two offices one in Washington the
other in Paris or outside of Paris
general Hawkins grew to prefer quite
strongly the World War one architecture
but again you know he doesn't have a
degree in architecture nor do why I
think they're they just well yeah they
just appeal you know more to but and I
read the in Primus piece written by the
gentleman from Williams College who was
here perhaps some of you were in that
audience I'm very glad that those who
purport to be in the business of
designing memorials today didn't have
anything to do with those sites
oh that's yeah keep up the good work so
this will be our last question for
tonight in your photograph photographs
of the cemeteries the Christian cross
was prominent and then we saw some
Jewish star of David's were there any
other religious symbols you came across
or you knew about I'm understanding now
that isn't the military supply like
Muslim religious symbol isn't there one
for atheists I don't know if or
Satanists are for wick Wiccans or other
pagan religions the the cross by the way
one of the ways that the ABMC was able
to win the argument on their being
crosses as the individual headstones and
Stars of David was particularly the case
of cross that's the symbol of sacrifice
so even to a non-christian you know the
cross might pass muster as a symbol of
sacrifice
are there any atheist guys who really
were atheist buried in those cemeteries
with Christian crosses or Jewish stars
probably but I don't know that hmm well
yeah that'll that old saying and no
atheists in foxholes but the the [ __ ]
issue the this Islamic issue has come up
more frequently in conversations and I
don't know not being an official you
know I don't know if a senior
representative from the ABMC were here I
don't know what he would might say to
that but during the first half of the
20th century as far as the American
government was concerned you were either
a Jew or a Christian
so at least that's that's certainly the
way it seems so thank you